moi j'ai pris goût au cigare quand
j'étais au tnp parce que je voyais je
n'avais jamais fumé de ma vie et je
voyais tous mes amis wilson sorano tous
à gérard qui fumait en répétant sans
arrêt des cigarettes et ça ne me donnait
pas envie je dire ça ne donne pas envie
de voir quelqu'un fume une cigarette on
se dit que c'est une maladie sont
complètement malade il y avait un
camarade qui était adressé serre qui lui
arrivait au foyer et avec un cigare il
avait pas d'autre moyen fumée au loin où
on commence à peine 1 toscane ou bien
même un voltigeur aucun point à vannes
et là je voyais un type qui prenait son
plaisir je veux dire est ce le sud il
lie à caudry là il ya quelque chose
d'intéressant
j'ai été lui demander quelques conseils
et malheureusement il me les a données